there are places in america whose names
are burned into the country's
consciousness
the alamo where a small band of texans
held off mexican forces for 13 days
has become a symbol of defiance no
surprise donald trump picked a town
named in honor of this place to make his
last stand this week
the real alamo though loyal fans like
the edwards family believe impeachment
only energizes his supporters
peaceful or not realistically the way
that i see the whole impeachment thing
is
it's just a ploy he's got what how many
days left until his term is over
and on top of that if he gets impeached
what's going to happen after that his
presidency is over
but his base is going to be stronger he
could do anything at that point he could
start a company everybody would leave
their jobs to go work for him like at
this point it's all just
theater it's political theater that's
what it's come down to i am hoping
that it doesn't get violent but the way
that they keep pushing things it makes
no sense as to why they're doing certain
things
and it seems like they're doing it just
americans like it seems like they're
just doing it just
to dig the knife deeper and twist it the
names of the alamo are now figures of
history
the trump faithful not ready for his
name to join them
i voted for trump i wouldn't want to sit
down and have a beer with him
douglas and cheryl are among those who
say trumpism is here to stay
that constituency is not going to go
away it's going to it's going to stay
because it's
it's they believe in what they believe
and that's that's not going to change
because of
somebody else's political tax tactics
or because somebody else believes
differently
texas is proud of its reputation for
standing alone at the state capital
there's increased security with protests
expected
without a doubt america is in what i
call an ideological civil war
and the head of the texas republicans
hardly talking it down
do you think impeachment is the right
thing to do i think that that is a very
divisive thing to do and i think it's a
very vindictive thing to do
that's not going to help to heal this
country what it looks like is once again
you're trying to take a punitive action
against a person because you hate them
here and across america there is real
nervousness about how far protesters
might go
seven days until the president leaves
and everyone
still wants their say greg milam sky
news texas